in Afghanistan a new video from al-qaeda
shows the continued threat of terrorism
nearly two decades after the 9/11
attacks the group's leader Ayman
al-zawahiri wants to inspire so-called
lone wolf attacks against the US and its
allies al Qaeda is not the only terror
group threatening Afghanistan's
stability in a CBS News exclusive
Charlie d'Agata joined us trained Afghan
special operations forces hunting Isis
on a dangerous night patrol in Kabul we
met up with the heavily armed elite
fighting unit in the early hours on an
empty street how dangerous of these
missions dangerous the commander told us
because the suspects probably don't have
a car bomb only ak-47s in Kabul
dangerous is a matter of perspective the
target a suspected Isis commander
believed to be holed up somewhere in
this slum on the edge of the capital
we're told to stay close and keep quiet
the neighborhood is a notorious hotbed
of extremism then we move into a warren
of pitch-black narrow alleyways
surrounded by abandoned buildings
soldiers with night-vision scan the
horizon on the lookout for snipers or
suicide bombers lurking in the shadows
these US and NATO trained forces are
among the best equipped and battle
hardened soldiers in the country a key
component of America's plan to ensure
terrorist organizations like Isis and
al-qaeda find no safe haven here inside
they identify their target and cuff him
one of the things they did was they
confiscated his phone and once they did
that because they were tracing his phone
they knew that they had their man sir do
you understand why you've been arrested
tonight we're against Isis he said
they're killing people he says he's been
set up by a resentful neighbor whatever
the timetable for a drawdown
US military officials tell us this is a
vision of the future Afghan forces
directed by US intelligence striking a
common enemy before they can strike
first
for CBS this morning Charlie d'Agata
Kabul